Задача цих військових - відбити позиції, які захопила ворожа диверсійна група.
Штурмова група вибиває диверсантів з окопів. Двох беруть у полон.
Пригнись, пригнись! Сєрий, передаю!
Наша група закріпилася, спостерігаємо, ведемо спостереження. Як прийняв? Прийом.
Наша група закріпилася, тримає оборону.
Це навчання протидиверсійних резервів.
Вони працюють на північному кордоні України.
Військові фіксують тут до десятка спроб проникнення російських ДРГ щомісяця.
Змінилося те, що їх присилають сюди з інших регіонів РФ,
присилають спеціально навчених, найкраще підготовлених.
Це підрозділи ГРУ ГШ РФ,
підрозділи армійського комплекту сил спеціальних операцій.
Це люди, які заходять зі спеціальною зброєю, спеціальною підготовкою,
люди, які хочуть робити зло на українській території.
Цілі ДРГ - і військові, і цивільні.
Якщо їм вдається проникнути непоміченими,
диверсанти можуть працювати на території супротивника по кілька діб.
Замінування кордону не гарантує цілковитого захисту.
У складі ДРГ зазвичай діють сапери.
До того ж ЗСУ не можуть мінувати все підряд.
Протипіхотні міни. Україна підписала міжнародну Женевську конвенцію -
вони мають бути тільки в керованому варіанті.
РФ не підписувала такої міжнародної конвенції.
Вони можуть розкидати їх уздовж усього державного кордону.
А ми можемо тільки там, де є за цим спостереження.
Російські ДРГ діють здебільшого на кордоні з Сумщиною і Чернігівщиною,
а також на Харківщині.
На півночі зручніша для них місцевість - багато лісів.
З білоруського боку - тихо.
Помічати неочевидне й самим бути непомітними -
цьому навчають тих, хто працює проти ДРГ.
Тут дуже велика специфіка у цього всього.
Терпіння, навченість і адаптивність -
це ключові фактори, які грають у цьому роль.
Хоча новин з північного кордону небагато, ситуація тут напружена.
Лише за останній тиждень листопада російські диверсанти
тричі намагалися потрапити на українську територію.
Дві спроби ЗСУ відбили.
Ще один прорив призвів до втрат.
Віталій, досвідчений боєць, так описує відчуття на цій "невидимій" війні.
Постійна невідомість. І на позиціях, і не на позиціях,
у переміщенні між позиціями.
Вернувся назад, відійшов трішки від лінії раз на тиждень одяг випрати,
помитися, побритися - кажу відверто, як є, звичайні банальні повсякденні речі -
може статися, що вони будуть останні через такі групи, які висуваються.
Аби бути готовими до бою будь-якої миті, військові не перестають тренуватися.
Дрон!
На сотнях кілометрів порослого лісами кордону безпілотники - незамінні.
Вони допомагають вчасно помітити ДРГ,
оцінити сили противника, коригувати артилерію.
Дмитро, який ще нещодавно керував дронами під Бахмутом,
тепер як інструктор навчає інших.
Як мінімум, дрони можуть висіти і вести пряму трансляцію лінії зіткнення.
Це робиться ротацією, тобто "каруселькою".
Два пілоти, для прикладу, один піднімає дрон в повітря і знімає.
У нього починає сідати батарея, він своєму колезі каже:
"У мене сідає батарея, підміни мене".
Також можна їх вражати FPV-дронами,
які можуть осколково-фугасний заряд нести з собою,
і ДРГ будуть просто розлітатися.
Ось один з останніх прикладів:
за допомогою дрону-камікадзе нацгвардійці знищили
моторний човен російських диверсантів на Херсонщині.
На півночі ж, як запевняють у Командуванні об'єднаних сил,
в України зосереджені такі ж сили, як і у РФ.
І діють ЗСУ дзеркально.
У нас державний кордон України на території
Сумської і Чернігівської областей - кількасот кілометрів.
Вони обирають ніч, туман, сніг, яри, русла річок -
це люди, які навчені проникати за будь-яких погодних умов.
Я хочу сказати, що й ми не сидимо склавши руки.
Ми теж ведемо активні дії. Це війна. Ми робимо подібні речі.
Українські ж диверсії дістають значно далі.
Один з прикладів - дії легіону "Свобода Росії" і "Російського добровольчого корпусу".
Вони не раз заходили на територію РФ у Білгородській області.
Такі прориви відбуваються й досі.
Але, як кажуть у легіоні, їх рідше висвітлюють.
Також наприкінці листопада сталося два вибухи на залізниці в Бурятії -
за шість тисяч кілометрів від українських кордонів.
За неофіційними даними, це успішна спецоперація СБУ.
Інформації жодної щодо відновленої роботи навіть в російській ЗМІ нема.
Вони просто абсолютно замовчують цю тему.
Проблема Росії насправді - її розміри і території.
Це є для неї великою проблемою.
По-друге, є доволі значний спротив і всередині Росії,
і є багато небайдужих росіян, які, я так розумію,
готові співпрацювати з нашими спецслужбами,
які прекрасно розуміють злочинність режиму Путіна.
Збої в роботі залізниці, вибухи на об'єктах енергетики і військових підприємствах -
усе це має не лише психологічний ефект, а й заважає РФ ефективно воювати.
Звісно, там десь ходять легенди, що це виключно БпЛА,
але враховуючи те, що ці вибухи, як правило, відбуваються не зовнішньо,
а внутрішньо і наносять чималу шкоду,
тобто це також можна, я думаю, що віднести до ефективної роботи наших вже диверсійно-розвідувальних груп.
Дуже важливо насправді створення ефекту симетричності,
показувати, що ми також маємо можливості
і маємо операції, якими ми можемо діставати до вас в тилу.
Українські військові небагато говорять про диверсійну і протидиверсійну діяльність.
Навіть навчання, які показують публічно, -
лише невелика частка того, чим займаються спеціально підготовлені підрозділи.
Комплектування груп, підготовка груп, озброєння -
в кінцевому рахунку це може зіграти на руку противнику.
Вони розуміють, що якщо працюють протидиверсійні групи,
вони можуть працювати проти цих груп.
Позитивний досвід не завжди показується, бо поки війна.
Після війни, думаю, будуть писати книжки, фільми знімати.
Може, подивимося, якщо пощастить.
Вчитися протидіяти ворожим ДРГ -
для військових робота й життєва необхідність.
Адже супротивник так само готується і тренується.
А поки триває війна, про спокій на кордонах не йдеться.